e
any Lads when I was in high school in
Rhode
Island yeah I lived in E Greenwich for a
while oh I think they're okay over here
yeah they went both which ones do you
have you justed I went to the end yeah
okay just leave those on the table with
the box over there and would be
is this on can everybody hear me thank
you very much um I'd like to take this
opportunity to welcome everybody to this
new committee which is called education
funding it's also responsible for Career
Technical education and higher education
uh legislation as well um we broke this
up simply because we had so many bills
last year and you all know how many we
were rifling through and we had a total
of 23 5 some odd bills over the course
of that bium it was very difficult so
now we broken up and I think this will
allow us the opportunity to really
explore and research and and really
those topics that need more done to them
and we know what those topics are so
that will be what this committee is up
to um because we are limited in time
this morning at at at 11 o'clock we do
have the folks coming in the both the
chancellors coming in from the
University system the community college
system I'd like to get right on with
this um we have a number of members here
that are are are not a number we have
some that are not here seeing they're on
Dual committees and they may be over at
Ways and Means or Finance or something
such as that this time and so they will
be here uh later on several of them will
be here at 11 o'clock even when higher
ed moves in on us right here today so
what I'd like to do is um go around the
room quickly and each of the committee
members that are here would you please
ruce yourselves by the way where the
placards are right now it's not
necessarily where they're going to be
they will be assigned later on um I'll
be working with uh folks on the
committee uh we do have beside me my
chair Vice chair uh uh representa
spillsbury and to the right the ranking
uh member of our committee uh representa
luno and we'll explain the nature of
everybody's jobs as we go around
representa her will you please because
you're also a chair too on this
committee not this committee but another
committee representative from
representative from where the pseudo
Finance yes just go around please
Hillsboro representative Raven peoples
from
Lichfield I'm repres representative Pete
mahagan from
Pembrook and representative dick Ames
from Jaffrey
okay representative hope Damon I'm from
cyon I represent the Sullivan County
towns of aworth langon lemster Goan
Washington Springfield sonap Cen and
Terry spillsbury uh from Charlestown
representing Newport unity in char Char
town if you've seen me on lists you see
Walter please call me Terry um third
term I was on ways and means but I've
also had an active interest in education
and was part of the sub special
subcommittee last year so good to be
over on
education and I'm Rick lad I come from
hail I've chaired education for a number
of years now I'm looking forward to
chairing this committee which is dealing
primarily with the funding policies
education he Brown I I represent
Kingston and East Kingston and have
served on the local school board for two
terms I'm Wayne Burton this is my fifth
term my third on House Education I'm
also a town counselor in the town of
Durham I'm Sally fellows I represent
Plymouth Ashlin and holderness uh last
year I was on Ways and Means and um I
worked for 30 years in the Department of
my name is Suzanne crean I'm from
Manchester a public school teacher for
years representative Tony Weinstein I
newfields I'm Tracy Bicky I represent
Penacook board one in conquered and I am
uh 35y year Public School educator and I
am chair of my school board mayor Mac
Valley School Board Penacook Salsbury
Webster bosin and
Lon so I'd like to welcome all our
members to the committee this will be
quite a trip and we'll enjoy it uh we
have six new members here on our
committee and 12 that are returning that
have been either on this committee or
other committees in previous years so a
lot of talent what we're going to do
next is I'm going to go through some of
the process processes and procedures
that I I use when I'm running this
particular committee and I believe
everybody should have a copy of the
two-sided sheet that unfortunately I I I
started putting this together last night
when I'm watching
the Rams and the Vikings play football
or at least some of them were playing
football and um so it's kind of
disjointed but I think all my points are
here on it so I'd like to just go that
does everybody have a copy of that right
here in front of us right now it's just
a singular sheet no two holes in it uh
okay the the first bullet simply is what
our responsibilities are and when we we
developed this committee we developed
with the intent of doing just what I
said earlier of looking at those
policies which are associated with
funding so when we move things on to
represent Earth's Committee in division
two that we actually done some a little
bit more homework and and looking at
those fiscal measures asso assciated
with that policy there's implications
going both ways and we're looking at
those big issues which we went through
yesterday uh over with doe and we were
we were there and we looked at the
foundation formula we looked at the
building Aid stuff we looked at Career
Technical education special education uh
special education Aid catastrophic as we
some call we've been warned don't call
it cat Aid anymore I that's in my brain
and I always call it cat Aid and so
there's a number of issues and we and
also issues associated with higher
education which I think we'll hear a
little bit about today so that's where
our direction is now going down uh the
bullets here so quickly because we do
have limited time if anybody has a
question as I'm going through these
please just put your hand up I don't
have my gavel with me they're all at
home and I had a little six-year-old
today playing with it one of them and
and it was taken from the lowboy where I
was supposed to take it to work and I
didn't I think he has it probably
somewhere in his
backpack so at any rate um going down
through this B buttons right here our
bullets we we have a security plan here
in this building and through the Capitol
Building all through the L and on this
campus as you all know if in fact there
is a security issue I've highlighted
that phone number which you may want to
put in the speed dial on your phones
um normally and what we always do is
there there's always a person by The
Doors right here which is given the
assignment if we are having an issue uh
from the public or some other type of
issue which we need some kind of
response then the wink and a nod goes to
that person the person goes out and does
that but also we also will try you push
the the the uh cell phone and and a Comm
unication will be made and we can get
response here very very
quickly not be laboring that we'll get
into it a little bit more um the
chairman of the committee that's myself
the vice chair and the ranking member
that's represented luno beside
represented spillsbury here and then we
also have our clerk sitting beside me
representative Brown is new to the game
she's going to get some training
tomorrow she's been involved though in
government and and in
education and I look forward to working
with uh representative Brown here um she
will have that training as I said again
tomorrow but recognizing I was a clerk
once and I was removed from my job by
the speaker at that time for a reason I
don't want to go into um so at any rate
um the we got to be respectful of our
clerks you know they they're they're
when we want to start acting and doing
some we have to always check are you
ready Pam and so so that's uh so very
very important job probably at when
we're business here her her job is one
of the most important because it's part
of the statutory record or the intent
and all the records associated with the
notes which are taken now you tell me
yeah you're welcome
um we always start our meetings off with
announcements and what's going to happen
with the date in front of us um are we
going to learn also if there is a person
who knows at that time that I'm going to
be out I have another meeting going to
have to testify it later on so we can
build our schedule during the day around
that movement I know that's going to
happen with people here that are in dual
committees we're going to have movement
back and forth so if you're going to be
out a given day I I'd like to know that
or if you're for example going to be
doing an activity at at another
committee where you're exec at the same
time let us know that
um going down these bullets here just
some the
protocols we've had I've been in this
house here a number of times when we've
actually had the governor come in or the
governor's wife come in that happened
with Governor Lynch when he was here the
his wife came in and she wanted to
testify along with himself when a
governor comes in we stand up and and
and a matter of respect to the the
position the chief justice as well and
we be I have to be cognizant of that um
it's it's a matter of courtesy and it's
just professional
ethics uh sponsor co-sponsor introduces
a bill if a no-show chairman May appoint
a Committee Member these are not in
order I'm jumping here but I'm just
going in the order of the sheet we've
had sometimes when we posted a
hearing and either the sponsor or any
co-sponsors none are here but we have
members of the public who travel down
from cook or up from Rochester and they
want to testify so what we'll do is I
will appoint a person on the committee
to introduce the bill the person on the
committee doesn't have to take ownership
in the bill at all and try to defend the
bill just introduce the bill and that
will be part of the record the pink card
is filled out by that in individual that
do it and and we go on but we respect
the people have come down or up or
across or from to you know take their
testimony we may in fact if we recognize
we need more we can also take that
testimony and then recess and come back
and take that bill up later uh or or
gather information in other
ways um Senate uh testimony heard first
um we I think you've had this in your
training for the new but folks but when
Senators come in we try to get them in
and out of here they are often times on
two or three different committees and
they're running so let's just recognize
that they are uh busy people so I will
also sometimes jump them in the order
and may have a stack of pink cards we've
had some bills in here where we can be
discussing a bill in a hearing all day
long and and so we will just jump the
Senators up and bring them in and take
care of them
uh bills with financial notes are early
bills the early bills I think the date
is what March 6th that we have to report
them out by and unfortunately sometimes
we get notice that you have an early
Bill all the bills haven't been issued
to committees at this time and so we
just don't know and and and then we're
also waiting the for the fiscal notes
and that's another reason why we have
broken apart uh the the Committees here
so that we will I I think when they're
seeing a request from the education
funding uh committee for the LBA will
help uh initiate and expedite that
fiscal reporting process to us so we'll
have that information available to us
from the agencies and the Departments or
the
bureaus uh hearings do not require a
quorum years and years ago I remember
sitting in here at a hearing only two
members present and it was on a noow dat
and it wasn't called and that was way
back I think we're talking now back to
2008 2009 in that era um so we can
conduct a hearing but in the executing
bills we must have a quorum we must have
a quorum and while we're talking about
that I'll jump and just take this other
item up if anybody's going to be absent
and needs a replacement we have to know
of that absence the prior Day by the
Clos the shop on that day so if we have
for example a an exact session coming up
on the Wednesday by Tuesday afternoon to
close the shop we need to know who's
going to be here and who's not going to
be here and you let your ranking member
know if you're on the Democratic Party
in the vi or the vice chair of the
majority party here or myself know that
they will contact those offices and a
replacement will be
found but that's very very important
it's also if you're not and when
you're calling in saying I'm not going
to be there you're not going to be there
uh if you show up on the next day that
is not going to work so you know if
you're you're being replaced you don't
show up the day you're being replaced on
the campus
anywhere okay going on down uh Sim bills
require larger rooms we may have that
occur here on Thursday this week when
we're dealing with uh hb15 that's
Universal EFA Bill uh in the past we've
gone to rep's Hall uh We've also gone
and and lately we've developed the other
process where there are other rooms
available where the Overflow can go
there and the bill is being streamed
over there as well and so then I will
announce over there we have so such and
such person will be coming up next and
so and so is on Deck just like you're
watching a baseball game and so the ones
across the way will be able to get
themselves together and be ready to come
in and
testify those occasions also bring in
the the concept that we may have to
reduced amount of time we're allowing
the public to
speak my policy on this committee is
that the prime sponsor of a bill is
entitled to have more time than a person
that's going to come and be a co-sponsor
or some other member of the public who
wants to speak that's just been policy
of Education I believe some other
committees do the same thing if the
prime sponsor has a very detailed Bill
and we've had some bills come in that
have 27 Pages or so that takes a lot of
discussion and in and and presentation
to this committee we will allow that
time to that be done but subsequent
people coming for and testifying may be
given time limits depending upon the
load of people we
have also a policy I have is that we
have a number of parents that travel in
and some of them have really young
children ages one and younger and we
just don't want to hold them up here as
long that long so if I see a mother or
father out there with young kids running
around helping them expedite it and get
it done I will move them up in the in
the amount in the list of those to
testify and also we'll try and look at
those people are traveling those greater
distances and and help them out too as
well um especially in the winter here
when it gets dark and it's it's not fun
driving home and I know that because I
have to drive an hour and a half to get
here every day and so the the the dark
hours are not not
fun uh I talked about testifying times
we may limit those times to two or three
minutes a person depending upon the
crowd that we have and we do that I
usually have the vice chair represent
spillsbury with their cell phone right
here clocking it and then we have to you
know tell okay time's up and you yeah
we'll we'll stretch that sometimes for
another 15 seconds or so but that's
about the limit cuz we have to be
everybody um going down here I talked
about the children the breaking breaks
during meetings you can see I have a a
bottle of water here um I used to have
an old hood coffee small coffee thing
and people always thought I'm up here
drinking coffee milk that there was
water in it but then of course it was
Plastics and all that stuff that's not
good for you and all that so now we went
to this aluminum I don't know it's an
aluminum but at any rate uh we I do
encourage you to have fluids uh there to
drink um uh while we're going through
this process this is a very very dry
building and I I start recognizing
Myself by 11:00 unless I'm starting to
drink something it gets difficult and
it's not healthy so please you know
bring some liquids with you some say
it's water I don't object to something
that's made out of water that's in your
bottle just make don't go all the way we
know where I'm going uh but uh it's very
very very important and also any member
that has pardon me no Irish whiskey
that's exactly exactly right and if
somebody has to get up and and and and
go to a washroom down the hallway do it
if you have to get up for some reason go
to another committee do it but let's try
to do it at a time when maybe if there's
somebody testifying at that particular
moment wait till that person stops
testifying and then do the movement and
never when you're coming back in cut in
front of a person that's testifying
that's just like in the speaker we used
to have a rule here too that on cell
phone use during your your your
uh while you're in committee here and
this was years ago I think this was back
when Mary guile was um chair and
anybody's cell phone that went off
bought everybody else lunch that day and
so you know put it on mute and mine's on
mute right now uh but uh it it's it it
is distracting when those things are
going off and while we're talking about
this technology how I have my computer
right here um and I I know that
especially in terms of the the clerk
some clerks like to take their notes uh
on the computer that's very very
acceptable if you're using your computer
during an exact session to look up
statutes and all that that's wonderful
do it but let's be careful how much
we're using this computer during a
public hearing where we're taking
testimony from people people it's it's
I've testified before in some committees
where that's occurring and sometimes you
wonder are they listening to me are they
hearing what I'm presenting and so so
let's I I understand there may be some
situations for example if you're in a
hearing and you don't have yourself but
maybe you have a notice that comes over
your computer that a made arrangements
with the person down in finance and
they're going to let me know 5 minutes
before I'm supposed to be down there a
testify and it comes in on might be
that's fine but um let's try to not use
those those computers during the hearing
process um it's it's it's uh I think it
really sends a message to somebody
that's coming from the other side of the
table from
us um breaks meetings rooms are dry
drink water oh also here's something
that I had a rep tell me the other day
thank goodness you told us this uh
representative lad uh early on they coat
racks up and down the hallway here and
some folks hang their coats on the coat
racks CU years ago when I'm sitting on
this committee i m been my first year or
second
year 2008
2009 that a fella had his jacket out
there and there's other kinds of
hearings going on when he came out his
jacket was gone somebody had mistaken
his jacket or taken it
and unfortunately in the pockets of his
coat were the keys to the car and his
wife had to drive over from the main
border with New Hampshire with the other
set of the keys for that car later on
that evening to get him home and so be
careful if you hang your jacket in the
hallway we do have a coat rack in here
you're welcome to use it but if if you
if you're hanging up in the hallway
check to make sure everything that's of
value is out of their pocket so that
jacket CU it could disappear on
you all righty
uh when you're in a hearing the last uh
bullet on that page there um when we're
re in committee members and people are
testifying please do not engage in
running debates with the person that's
testifying you know that's really
important we're here to hear and you
hear things that some sometimes you're
not comfortable with or sometimes you
think well that's not where I am but
that's not the purpose of the hearing
the purpose of the hearing and that's
the beautiful thing about this state
where we have 400 reps and we're
representing so many people throughout
this state and the ratio is smaller than
any other state in the country as far as
public to representative we have the
same opportunity for people coming in to
these committees from our public and so
we do have a lot of testimony in
hearings especially on those hot times
topics Charter Schools
efas
funding they're all hot but uh and and
we'll have a lot of people test just
don't get into a running debate with
them and start expressing your personal
opinion and that favorite question some
people like to ask is would you believe
and they go on and express their opinion
we don't need to hear that um uh the the
question shouldn't be going to them we
should be ask you know
the the question does go to them but
they don't want to hear what your
opinion is because then it's saying to
them well what what their opinion
doesn't
count um I spoke about use of
Technology uh technical questions or
information request of a public member
must be asked of the public at the
discretion of the chair so if in fact
there is a person on the committee that
for example we've had the it happen in
executive sessions where we just don't
have all the information yet and there's
some question so we have people out
there with orange bad badges I see Brian
I see Jerry out there and others
um they may have an answer and represent
Luna you've asked several times could we
have somebody from the could we get some
more information on this one and the
question has to come to the chair and
the chair uses the discretion yes or no
I'm going to allow that or I'm not going
to allow that to occur
so so please if if we need more
information for some reason or if you
need more information direct that
question to me and if there's somebody
out there that can help and if it's a a
a a question that I feel appropriate to
be asked at that moment then we will ask
those people and they don't have to
respond out there they can say nope I'm
not going there and
so that's that's that that one right
there um remove moving stickers or
buttons or those expressions of where
you are on a particular issue uh I frown
on that I really frown on that in this
committee my job here is to represent
everybody on this committee regardless
what party you're on I'm representing
the whole committee as a whole here and
ensuring that it's fair and there's no
discrimination going on on this
committee some people don't understand
that because some people think well here
I am a republican I'm supposed to be
supporting the Republican perspective no
I'm respecting the meaning of a hearing
and so everybody has a fair opportunity
to import impart their position to us
and do it in a respectful
manner so uh that's really important
when we're coming to these buttons and
these Expressions I support this or that
um I don't want anybody testifying with
that we don't allow placards in this
room and uh and it's not like the US
Congress where they can have all kinds
of charts and things behind them we
don't have that we will have an occasion
where we've had bills which are are
are dealing with a specific issue maybe
it's a health issue or a a bill to uh
get more uh defibulators in schools and
we want to name that bill in memory of a
person or something such as that and you
may have a parent come in with a
photograph of their child that happens
and it's it's a sensitive issue it's one
where I use common sense on that and and
and generally speaking we'll allow that
to
happen okay going on down here anybody
has questions says I go please ask
them yes couple from the first page you
don't sure go
ahead I might have missed it it's Point
number five spor or a co-sponsor of this
you may return to your seat but you will
not be recognized can you clarify that
please yes um represent M you may have
have uh have presented a bill you may be
sponsoring a bill and you're sitting out
there and you're presenting because
you're the first person to
present some of the committee me Members
prefer on a bill just go back to the
chairs and sit there throughout that
bill you are also allowed though by our
rules to come sit in your chair up here
on the committee but you cannot get into
the conversation during that hearing
process you can't be asking other people
to testifying questions about that bill
is this an attempt to to avoid
micromanaging a bill that you're trying
to like shepher through you have
ownership on the bill so everybody knows
where you where you are on that bill
you're coming in then with a biased
position and so now you're asking
questions and that's giving you an
opportunity to testify more than once
but twice or three or four times if
you're using your position the the other
one was um I I assume if I come in to a
meeting like on Thursday and I have
questions on my laptop that's not going
to be a problem or or an offense I'll
just open the laptop and ask the
questions that are listed it's not in
terms of typing but it's just that kind
of thing would be okay if you're just
reading your questions that you pre pre
right not typing but just just reading
things yeah let me let me give you
something an example that occurred um
years and years ago we had several bill
come in regarding Northern path that was
the line coming down from uh Hydro
Quebec down through New
Hampshire and that was a hearing that I
attended um and had a bill uh one of the
bills uh in in the hopper on that
particular and I was in the rep's
hall and we had the lobbyist for one of
the organizations sitting out there
texting questions to people on the
committee to ask of other people
testifying that we don't want to happen
so if you have your comp computer open
there and you're communicating with
people out there during the hearing
process that's a no no we don't do it
but if you're doing it if you just
essentially the same as having a
question on it but yeah so I probably
better to write them on the paper it
probably is because you're not going to
have a lot of time for a lot of
questions you know remember this is not
a debate this is a situation so you
should probably try to prioritize your
questions and as things go more
information comes out you may have
another one come up I understand that
but try to allow others on the committee
I in fact you can't ask a question until
you have permission from the chair to
ask that question I will try to ensure
that everybody has had an opportunity to
get what's on there you know
plate spoken to do you have
a thanks very much M Mr chair to um
representative mahan's first um question
yeah yeah pardon me yet to um um to
represent mahan's first question um with
respect to co-sponsors who testify
during a hearing how about co-sponsors
on a bill who do not testify during a
hearing it depends on the chair um
whether or not uh those co-sponsors may
be able to ask questions if you're a
co-sponsor and you're not testifying but
you're sitting on this committee you can
ask questions good yeah that that that's
always been the practice of this but
usually when we're we're having for
example if you're asking a question
represent mahagan and you're getting an
answer you can follow up you can ask
permission of me to have a followup on
that to try and maybe get your your
question further
explained but I'm not going to go for
follow-up follow-up followup so so if
you want to follow up your question go
to the chair chair will say yay or nay
and you can ask the question I'd like to
say one last thing on a personal level I
I am extremely hearing impaired and so
if you see me poking on this it's really
to adjust the volume because at times
the volume uh doesn't quite come through
so I'll be poking on this sometimes as a
matter of convenience for the volume
just so that people know people who
don't know me it's something that they
will say not to text but to fix thank
you okay that's something that those are
the types of uh things that I need to
know of because then I can also let Jen
for who is our committee researcher and
a lot more to do than just research and
we have a committee assistant too that
might help in terms of how we locate you
on the committee um my past experience
was I was came out of the military and
then went into education business became
a elementary teacher then principal
administrator and we always knew the
kids in the class which had those types
of issues and we tried to seat them in
the right position okay the Acoustics in
this room are wonderful thank you so
much you're welcome going back to the
second page here yes uh yes just for for
the new new people in terms of a
follow-up question that um I might rule
I've been using is that it has to be
related to the first question you asked
that can't be a new question and also do
you watch for people to go like this or
you watch for people who turn on their
red light um when they want to ask a
question no I I look for the signal that
I have a question and then when you're
recognized then you put your red light
on okay thank
you um going on down here I'm trying to
find out where I dropped off here uh
something that I have not mentioned
already
um want to deal with the how we deal
with our clerk right here and
representative Brown is new to the game
but when we're in executive session and
we've had our discussion and we're ready
to put the motion we're ready to go
ahead and take that
vote and we've we're going there and
before I always look to the clerk
because she's sorting through paperwork
here trying to get down because she's
going to have to do the roll call and
it's done by roll
call I will you know look at her and if
she's ready then I will again say the
motion on HB
175 is
OTP maybe otpa it may be itl it may be
to retain and we'll go through that when
we get into more exact session stuff but
I'll I'll I'll I'll say hb1 52 whatever
it might be and what that bills about
the motion is
OTP so everybody knows what we're voting
on it's possible somebody may have just
walked in but you got to be in the
committee room in place here if if if
you can't walk in and we're also already
in that process of voting you're not
going to be able to
vote now we've had a lot of situations
in the past where we've tried to
accommodate and we have we try to do
that I often times work with the vice
chair and represent luno the ranking uh
representative here to make sure that we
know everybody's going to be here at a
certain time that we try to do but if
you're not here when it's put to the
Motions put then you're not going to be
able to vote that's in our
rules house rules not Rick lad's rules
okay going on down here I think you jump
which one did I jump over oh I did the
stickers starting here no
subcommittees this year we're we're
dealing with issues which are are
issues which have been dealt with every
year since I've been here
funding back in uh 2011 when we put this
formula together every year thereafter
when be chopped and chiseled off the
sides 2018
20202 or the commission report that you
were on there represent L and I was on
the the issue
becomes when we're we're we're looking
at these bills which are coming
as
um there may be a need for a work
session and there will be with these
committees now when we're dealing with
the
funding and I prefer to use Committees
of the whole I've always been a
committee of the whole person other
words you know rather than choosing well
we're going to have two Dems and three
Republicans but I always make sure if
it's a committee to hold then the
chairman is the first named person of
course it's because it's a committee of
the whole when you're coming out of a
subcommittee the report is made back to
the full committee and the the report is
always made by the chair of the
subcommittee or the committee of the
whole I would make that recommendation
or or i' I'd appoint somebody to do it
because I shouldn't be making that
recommendation unless I turn the gavel
over but when we have a smaller
subcommittee then the subcommittee has
the responsibility of doing the research
and Gathering research taking testimony
it's conducted just like a regular
hearing would be conducted and you also
then take action at the end of it just
like we did on the Joint Committee we
had last year which involved Ways and
Means finance and policy people we came
up with
recommendations and then it comes back
to the education committee or the
funding committee here and the
recommendation that's made by the
subcommittee is taken up first by the
whole committee so if the recommendation
of
the subcommittee was to itl the bill
that recommendation would come from the
person who has given the responsibility
to be the chair of the
subcommittee and that is appointed by
the chairman of the full committee if we
go that route and I'm sure we will I'm
sure we will go that year because one of
the things we're up against the clock as
we are right now but we're up against
the clock we have people that're being
shared from Dual committees right from
other
committees and some like representative
F or represent pich uh Muller um and uh
representative Maguire there are
Republicans here but they are also on
division two and effect of March
6 they're going to become very very busy
people and so it it's it's we're going
to have to hustle so we're going to have
to do a lot of our subcommittee work
early on and but we will continue just
because they have to go it doesn't mean
we have to stop working we're not going
to stop working we've taken a lot of
time in the past to look at some of
these bills which are are issues very
very complicated as you heard yesterday
it's not just special ed it's special
education Aid it's differentiated Aid
it's all those little innuendos and
nuances associated with
those topics which we have to get down
in and realize there's certain impacts
and there's money's coming from
different sources not just from the
education trust fund or the general fund
maybe from
Medicaid and how's that work in and
how's that impacting our costs and how
is it impacting our policy decisions on
delivering there delivering these
services to kids whether it be here or
some student that you all read in the
papers what happened in
Tennessee that comes back and we have to
be addressing issues such as
that okay so that's how the subcommittee
process will work and we will engage
that I guarantee you we will be engaging
that
process um executive session voting um
just one thing we can retain bills in
the first year of the
bium interim study is a
motion that's made in the second year
retain bill means we retained it we
don't have enough information on it or
we may be retaining it for another
reason there may be another bill that's
elsewhere in the Senate that's very
similar we're just kind of waiting
holding our cards find how things are
working there so we can move forward
with our retain Bill and maybe have to
Etc okay
um exact sessions okay chair recognizes
okay yeah
um I will on any motion made I will be
recognizing the person to make the
motion um so uh that's pretty um the
calendar I've oftentimes initially asked
what fiscal bill can any fiscal bills go
on consent and I have been told if the
costs are less than1
$1,000 which I see hers and Earth just
shaking yeah $110,000 is like tip money
but um when we're talking billion
million um so yeah you can't put
something like that on but the vote has
to be at if it's a two people saying nay
and the rest of the committee saying yay
we can put it on consent if nobody
objects we may have an objection I will
always ask
or somebody else may remind me to
ask consent like the placees on consent
I'll look around any objections to
placeing on
consent I won't see any hands flying up
so we'll put that on consent or there
may be one person objects I object to
putting that on
consent okay it's not going on consent
just because you vote no doesn't mean it
can't go on consent though if there's
two people that voted no I'll look at
them are is there going to be any con
concern no okay we'll put on
consent the when we're not putting
something on consent the person that's
making the
motion is the one and this is why
sometimes we have sometimes a hard time
getting somebody to make a
motion the committee report has to be
made by the person making the motion not
has
to unless you have a good buddy that can
write it for you and you agree to have
your buddy you write it and you put your
name on underneath that but the
committee report and we used to call
this the blurb and you'll sometimes hear
me say the you have to write the blurb
I'm meaning the committee report that's
what goes into the calendar and the
calendar should reflect what happened in
the committee and we don't want to see
committee reports written from that
person's individual perspective and
stating some things which were never
said in the
committee those reports have to come
back also to to myself regardless of
which party put forth the motion and
I'll check it over to make sure it's
expresses where we are and there's been
of course in the past we've had real
issues when it's been a 1010 vote we've
had some issues with all that but they
have to be approved by myself then they
will go on to our committee researcher
upstairs she'll look at it and then it
goes over to Paul Smith over the clerks
and to the speaker and the speaker has a
right to modify anything he
wants that's his job he can approve or
disapprove I can remember we used to
have a clerk not not our current C clerk
that would check everything and make
sure we crossed our tees and dotted her
eyes in the right subject and right
predicate and the right verb it was all
that and that was pretty tough for some
people and but uh and she had us
correcting
that okay I think we're running out of
time here
um if somebody has to take a break
anywhere time and if you like to take a
recess you can we can call for that
there I I I agree that every now and
then we need to get up and we need
stretch and need to shake it off a
little bit and then come back if
somebody's getting to the point where
they just got to get up and move give me
a signal and and we'll just call a short
recess a short break and and hit
off okay are there any questions because
we have a few minutes I I see we already
have one of our speakers
here
yeah per
me me
univ okay yeah yeah oh I didn't see
behind the
I yes represent fellows I just wondered
if you wanted to mention um about
amendments that people have to you know
bring in amendments if we will have a
number of amendments sometimes a person
that's testifying has an amendment
and the amendment they're saying here
I'd like to have this amendment you know
you taken up by the the
committee the amendment won't be taken
up by the committee if in fact there is
not a Committee Member on or there's a
Committee Member on the committee here
may want to take that and introduce it
that's fine that could be done like that
but sometimes we'll have other people
come in and say I got this amending
language that's
you know we may take that information
and we may design an amendment but that
amendment is not Amendment we can only
do amendments which are introduced by
somebody on this
committee now I might be sitting there
with a bill that I've sponsored and say
I've got this amendment it's already
made then I'm going to have copies of it
available or somebody else on you may
have copies available for the committee
that's something that that's okay seeing
that the person introducing the bill is
a member of this
committee so um if a senator comes in
with an
amendment that
amendment is not going to has for us to
take care it has to have a
representative on this committee on that
Amendment so we'd have to take that
Amendment and have it redrafted with a
name of an individual or the or the
committee as a whole on there uh before
we're going to take action on that
Senate Amendment
any questions on that yes representative
Burton not on that I had another
question I shouldn't have to say this
but uh when I was sitting at the seat my
last term a weapon came out of the purse
of one of the committee members and I I
would urge people if you are carrying a
weapon make sure the safety is on and
and better yet make sure it's unloaded
but it was a very traumatic moment over
here as you remember Mr chairman I
remember it thoroughly and WMUR
remembers it too because they were here
and there was a child on the
floor and that parent remembers
too and you were testifying and you know
it wasn't not more than 30 seconds later
I had a call from the
speaker and and of course we put recess
in and I we went across the hallway and
had a little friendly chat and I won't
say where it went from there but it was
handled very very very quickly and and
security can be here in just like that
um so I'm glad you brought that up uh
represent Burton um yes we've had
several situations like that where
weapons have dropped out onto the floor
not just in here but elsewhere in the
facilities
so take care of them you know if you if
you if you're
caring further questions okay let's take
a few minute break here stretch out a
little bit and we'll come back cuz we do
have the chancellors are both here now
and we'll start up in a few moments yeah
no
e
SLE okay everybody we're going to
countown here
um and try to get everybody in their
seats this is the hard thing when we
take breaks all the squirrels start
playing and it's hard to get everything
back in chairs but I we really do have
to get going and I want to be fair and
give about a half hour to each one of
our our schools and our levels of
Education here and so just because we're
starting a little late doesn't mean that
we're U going to necessarily stop right
at 12 there'll be some slippage on that
that so with this today higher education
is um an a topic that many many states
when it comes to legislation have a
separate committee for higher education
period and and uh they then have K
through 12 and some of them have as many
as three separate committees but they
don't meet as often as we do as as but
right now we're recognizing with all the
issues that are facing us CER technical
education and and higher education
they're not in separate silos
necessarily we're starting to see that
there's a blending from K through 12
right through to K through
16 and we've had a task force just
recently I'll take just a second or two
more where it was put together by the
governor this last year and we were
looking at issues associated with higher
education alignment strategies
efficiencies
access um
affordability transferability of credit
all those issues we are looking at which
are necessary because they're impacting
our Workforce and and careers and those
Pathways and the pathway just doesn't
start when you become a high school
graduate it starts when you're right in
the Elementary grades and we start
talking about for example the trades in
the middle school and we go on with that
and we kind of uh bring it right to the
high school and we've opened that up to
grades 10 11 12 in the CTE but also
Manchester has at 9 10 11 and 12 and so
education now is becoming very involved
at all levels in terms of these topics
and so today I think it's very important
that we um start looking at and thinking
about those 40 some odd recommendations
short and long-term initiatives that
came out of the governor's task force
which he put together and that was a
result of hb1
1450 and transferability of credit HB
1530 and so today we're going to have
just some starters here some information
for us available on what's going on with
higher education in terms of the
University system the community college
system um so I'd like to invite right
now the folks we flipped the coin or
maybe they mutually agreed upon it uh
Kathy prenter who is uh Chancellor for
the University system uh Kathy Welcome
to our committee uh welcome back to
house funding educa education funding
it's not
education uh good morning Mr chair um
members of the new house education
record can you hear me is that good no
let's see is that any
great there it goes it's going on and on
it's
magic
oh my name is Katherine preventure uh I
serve as the chancellor of our States
University
system I am um pleased to be here to
provide some orientation to the
committee um some of the information in
my material um which was passed out
during the break may seem basic but just
want to try to level set for everyone
and I'm happy obviously and always to
take any questions so the university
system on page one is three institutions
University of New hampsh Plymouth State
University Keane State
College the University of New Hampshire
and Durham Plymouth and Kean are
residential campuses there's a law
school um with UNH here in conquer and
then UNH Manchester is obviously in
Manchester more of a commuter College
our total enrollment this fall is
23,000 19,000 of those are undergraduate
so about 83% of our total enrollment is
undergraduate and UNH makes up about 69%
of that total enrollment plymouths at
17% and keen's at 14% our total
operating expenses last fiscal year were
$928 million we're a very large
Enterprise
20% of that spend is related to direct
research expenditures and research
expenditures have grown
75% since
2019 uh UNH is what's categorized as an
R1 University in the Carn Carnegie
classification of higher education
institutions it's the top rank if you
will of research institutions only 4% of
highered institutions in the country are
R1 and UNH for a University at size is a
little Powerhouse of research and
Innovation I'll talk a little bit more
about that later but but um really
providing students with an unbelievable
experience and partnering with business
across the state on research and
Innovation so on on this third page
number
three our University system is a
tremendous asset for the State of New
Hampshire it is a significant driver of
Economic Development and Workforce
pipeline educated Workforce Pipeline and
about 2,000 graduates a year enter our
Workforce here in New Hampshire
the university system has a $3.7 billion
economic impact on the state annually we
work with businesses directly our
faculty work with businesses across the
state to inform long-term curriculum
needs for Workforce and Innovation over
the long
term we have relationships with
thousands of businesses across the state
and that that provides close connection
between the employers and our students
our graduates and the research
Enterprise and you you're probably
familiar with Cooperative Extension
that's affiliated with UNH we have reach
across the entire State on so many
issues health and wellness food safety
agriculture Economic
Development as just as Cooperative
Extension has reached across the entire
State Plymouth State and Keen state are
deeply embedded in the regions of our
state where they're located so Plymouth
in The Lakes Region of North Country
region on slide four I just want to
provide like an undergraduate profile
because that's the vast majority of our
our student body as I mentioned earlier
our undergraduate enrollment this fall
is about 19,000 52% of those are New
Hampshire residents 30% of our um
College goers are first generation so
they're the first generation in their
family to attend college 86 6% of our
students receive financial aid and we
have um the highest graduation rate at
The Bachelor level of All publics in New
England and the top majors business
health profession psychology biology
Communications and
Engineering okay so on Slide Five where
does the state investment
go so this fiscal year fiscal 25 the
university system was fortunate enough
to receive 95 million in state support
um from the um general fund
budget of the 95 million about $81
million directly buys down instate
tuition for New Hampshire students so
New Hampshire resident tuition is less
than half of what tuition is charged for
out of state students and that over like
$7,000 per student is supported by the
state to buy down the tuition and make
it more affordable for our New Hampshire
residents to attend school here and then
the the balance of the appropriation
provides most of much of the support not
all of it for statutorily mandated
programs so Cooperative Extension
agricultural experiment station I'll
also say um pursuant to statute uh
National Guard receives free to tuition
so their tuition waivers their foster
care children receive tuition waivers
that's not included in here that's about
another $3 million a year in providing
tuition waivers for um National Guard
boster care and and other um statutory
requirements me keep going here so on
slide six because of increased State
Support over the past six years we've
held instate tuition flat for six years
so during a period of high inflation now
I'll also say enrollment has been
declining I'll get to that in a minute
our enrollment has been
declining and actually that's happening
all around New England but be excuse me
because we've been able to keep New
Hampshire resident tuition flat and
increased financial aid we've increase
the amount of financial aid our net
tuition and fees for New Hampshire
residents has actually gone down
years and on slide
seven that's where we talk about
enrollment
declining
so and I'm sure you're all aware that we
have the demographics in New England and
many regions of the country um are we we
have fewer high school graduates right
there's a a smaller pipeline so and in
New England where we have so many
colleges right there are colleges and
University many colleges and
universities in New England and so the
competition is fierce because the number
of students are on the
decline and our we're no different our
total enrollment since 2019 has dropped
about
133% for the first time this fall for
the first time since the fall of
2012 the number of our New Hampshire
students
increased and and I think in large part
because we've been able to keep tuition
flat because of State support and and um
and financial aid through various
financial aid
programs so we did see an uptick this
um this this this is the worrisome chart
because demographics show that
enrollment will continue to decline
because there are fewer
students and frankly this
isn't as much about the university
system as it is about the pipeline for
the future and Workforce we know from
working with business and Bia Workforce
housing and childcare are the top three
concerns that Mo most of business and
industry yeah worry about and with fewer
folks in the
pipeline how do we ensure that we have
an educated
Workforce half a dozen years from now
and again this is happening all over New
England so and other states actually are
doubling down in their investment to
keep their their students in their
states or to attract our students out of
state Maine is a good example you might
have seen Billboards up and down the 95
on you can go to the University of Maine
for the same tuition that you would pay
in state and that's all of New England
New York and New Jersey Sunni also has a
big social media campaign come to Sunni
for the same price you'd pay in your own
State um UMass L if you live within a
50- mile radius you can have instate
tuition well what's a 50- m radius from
L the population centers of New
Hampshire so the competition is fierce
because folks
recognize we could have a problem with
Workforce as the number of as the
decline okay so what are we doing about
it on Slide N what's the University
system doing about it we know at as
enrollment declines we need to keep
reduce our cost structure that the math
doesn't work if we don't so over the
last 5 years we have reduced faculty and
staff headcount our full-time faculty is
down about 5 and a half% our part-time
not our full-time fa our fulltime
employee headcount is down 5 a half% our
part-time employee headcount is down
19% I I looked at and you might say why
does she keep going back to 19 with
because I try to go back pre-co covid um
makes Trend analysis difficult um over
that period since 2009 no let me qualify
a little bit I'm not including Grant
funded positions because when grants
increase 75% over 5 years I you know I
pulled that out because there are
employees that work on the grant side
over that 5-year period our toal total
employee
compensation wages medical benefits
retirement contributions over that since
2019 grew
2% in a period where inflation Rose 23%
so again and you can tell that in our
the number of our headcount has come
down as our enrollments come
down that's not enough we've reduced
retirement contributions we've reduced
the medical plan and increased premiums
we've um sold buildings we're
demolishing buildings we're exiting
leases actually we're the system office
is exiting the lease that's it it is in
and we're moving on to the nhti campus
here in conquer later this year um and
we just went live uh we did make a big
investment in a new Erp it's enterprise
resource planning it's the it's the
technology that runs HR Finance we're
working on
student um that technology that that we
had SL have was 30 years
old and so we just went live December
21st with a new HR and finance to make
business process more efficient and over
time we expect
technology well let me ask
still Chancellor U well she been she
both yeah um are do you want to take
questions now or at the end or do you
want to get through first what whatever
is best for the committee okay why don't
we we'll take one question right now
represent luno so thank you very much Mr
and thank you very much Chancellor for
um for um as you're sort of getting into
the the the go the business plan plan
going forward I wanted to sort of back
up to um to page eight which seems to be
the the demographic data that that's
driving the business plan and we talked
quite about quite a bit about this and
Chancellor rumstein was was along with
you and and chair lad myself on the on
the that Governor's um higher education
task force but we talked about the uh
the changes in demographic data and and
um and how
that how how how this this you know line
um is following I think you mentioned
you know number of high school graduates
or something like that but clearly
there's a large percentage of high
school graduates in New Hampshire that
are that are not attending not seeking
post-secondary opportunities and I was
wondering to what extent do do those um
high school graduates become a a um
whatever the term is addressable Market
or available market for um for higher
education and could could could seeking
to grow our customer base beyond the
traditional customer base be um uh be be
something that um you know that that
would maybe you know help change this
trajectory so I I think 100% um Jen
Rubenstein and I talked talk about this
I just met with the new director of the
nhcu Micah Stark yesterday um Christiana
Thornton at Granite advance I I do think
for the
state and our our future Workforce and
economy that is an opport that is an
opportunity set because so many of our
um as you mentioned representative luno
there are a number of students in high
school
that going to school Beyond High School
is not even a twinkle in their eye and
as you know we need folks in the trades
we need folks with certificates we need
folks with bachelor's degrees we need
folks with Advanced degrees to have a
robust economy so how do we tackle
that actually my board's having a
presentation in June on what we're doing
between Grant and advance in the
University system to reach down to to
middle school because I think that's
frankly I think that's where we need to
really reach down in middle school so
that folks are aware of Early College
opportunities when you think about it
early college opportunities you get
college credit in high school that could
lead to a pathway to the community
college system and I'll talk a little
bit more about we now have a hundred
Pathways from the community college
system to the university
system so for for those folks that's a
really I I think a more affordable
option um
um but I think we need to be a little
more intentional about how we reach down
to the middle school and we're not there
yet but I do think that is an
opportunity set for the community
college system the university system and
again frankly it's really about our
quality of life here in New Hampshire
and the economy and the workforce in the
future I think you just gave a wonderful
introduction to Mark you in terms of
concurrent du enrollment and some of
those programs we have working for us
chanc robenstein and I are spending a
lot lot of quality time together
yeah yes ask a question um can uh
represent Burton pardon me it just
follows on with you as long as you we
don't want to take all Cathy's time from
her but go ahead do a quick one the last
time I think we met C uh Chancellor was
when we I I sponsored the
6525 resolution uh 5 years ago that we
would reach 65% of the workforce with a
post High School
credential in in 5 years by
2025 at the time New Hampshire was
sitting around
48% I have since talked to the Bia about
the possibility of renewing that goal
with a goal of
70% with a high post High School
credential by
2030 does that fit in any way with what
something we might want to
do
possibly I I um that sounds like a
absolutely laudable
goal I need to give some thought you
know I'd like to talk to others I'd like
to give some thought to how that works
what the cost is um I I I'll tell you
that at every corner right now we are
trying to reduce administrative cost we
don't have a choice you don't have much
of a
margin oh we're absolutely it's exactly
there's there's a very limited margin we
know we have to continue drilling down
into the cost structure so every
everything's um I don't want to make it
sound all about money but as the former
State Treasurer right now for higher ed
it's all about money so we need to make
sure we're meeting our
mission thinking about what we're doing
that's not part of our mission
and um that's that's a long answer but
but to point out I don't think that
study was done by HED it was done by a a
separate entity paid for by Delta Dental
paid for by the Bia and other people it
I don't think it was any cost to the
university system or the okay let's
let's move on though because we have
questions and we probably need a whole
day on this but uh okay go ahead I can I
can move very quickly through these
through these the rest of my I only have
a couple slides left take your time and
I I just want to um make sure folks are
aware of the Partnerships that we do
have across the state as um chairman lad
just mentioned um the community college
system and the university system are
partnering on many levels with these
transfer Pathways that have just been
announced um a direct admit program
where community college students will be
directly admitted into the university
system seamlessly if they meet
eligibility criteria uh we have a
multitude of
administrative collaborations that are
going on I mentioned we're moving the
system office to the nhti campus I I
just we we um the state as a whole can
really benefit by close partnership
between our two systems of public higher
education um again UNH and the
university system critical to the future
of New Hampshire's Workforce New
Hampshire Life Sciences we're deeply
involved with with that group um the
advanced manufacturing initiative
through the Bea we're involved in that
initiative um and internships I can't
say enough about internships we know
that out ofate students are twice as
likely to stay and work here in New
Hampshire if they participated in an
internship over 75% of our students do
participate in an internship 74 4% are
New Hampshire companies we have over
500 um internship locations across the
state with businesses and
employers and um it's also about
Innovation and that's you know you might
say well why should I why should
research matter why should it matter
that the university system particularly
UNH has increased research 75% since
2019 gets back to Innovation working
with business giving students Hands-On
experienced with that research
Enterprise and the other um just a
couple other things Plymouth State you
we need to meet our students where they
are Plymouth State received approval
from Nei which is the New England
accrediting body in the fall to offer
five I'm going to call them I call them
three-year bachelor's degrees but
they're applied bachelor's degrees with
less than 120 credits that a student can
finish in three years cyber security
business Polie studies robotics outdoor
Venture leadership I don't know if
you're aware there is a industry over in
the madok region Precision manufacturing
Diamond turning Optics lab with like the
global leader in Diamond turning Optics
and Keen state is the only four-year
College selected by the American Center
of Optics manufacturing to partner with
and theyve ke now through Federal
funding has an Optics d interning lab
over there there are a thousand people
working in this industry in six
companies over in the madok region I
mentioned the research um UNH is a
little Powerhouse for an institution at
size and if you've never had an
opportunity to go to the John olssen
Advanced manufacturing center over at
UNH I would be happy to
um try to organize a tour because you'd
be amazed at the collaboration with high
school students community college
students University system students
businesses it's all advanced
manufacturing and um it it it's a and
and we have a number of companies that
are Co collocated there so again just
examples of
the the tremendous asset that the
university system is to the state and
our future and the last slide is just
contact information I think the chairman
can confirm that if anyone at any time
has questions um feel free to shoot me
an email text call I will do my very
best to get answers to your questions
even today I might not be able to answer
all your questions but I will try my
very best to get answers thank you very
much uh are there questions from the
committee
representative y thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question it's
actually two sort of related questions
um could you just comment
about the 5 2% of un students or maybe
of the whole system are New Hampshire
residents and is that a Target
or you know is there a particular effort
and then parallel to that how does our
outof state tuition compare with other
New England
universities because I noticed that
we've decreased in the number of out of
state tuition students seems like more
than just the overall decrease in uh
enrollment thank you so the 52% is not a
Target we accept all New Hampshire
students who are eligible that want to
attend uh so so let's remember with
enrollment declining we have plenty of
capacity so New Hampshire students are
not um being denied entry at all um
again the competition in New
England there you know there's a I hate
to say there's a on every street corner
almost in New England right we have a
lot of competition so no we that's not a
Target we'd love to have more New
Hampshire students um but they have lots
of
options and um on out of state again
especially with other public flagships
that's primarily our
competition
um other states are doubling down so um
yeah we we can did you mention anything
about gr Granite guarantee you know how
how we're helping out with you know we
see the tuition rates here but what the
the student that is needing help where
there to actually is and one thing the
trustees we we've done we've we want to
hold the line saying this is a college
available to all our New Hampshire
students on opposed to Vermont where 80
percent of their students are out of
state students in in our state what was
that percentage we we stated the other
day Kathy was around 50 some odd percent
that were we're we we're where we want
to be well 52% of our students are New
Hampshire
residents um but again we have capacity
for we'd like to have more out of state
and more instate
students
yeah yeah no one one question yes go
ahead
thank you Mr chairman uh I I am the
father of eight children three four of
which were part of the UN University
system three to Keen one to Plymouth and
one to you no two to three no five of
the eight the two youngest decided not
to go to any University at all because
of the number that you put on slide
number four to me it's terrifying to see
that 86% receive financial aid what that
means is 8 86% of our University
students have aced egregious debt it's
not just small debt it's it's the size
of a decent car that they have to pay
off when they come out so my question is
um is there any way that you guys have
put because I know of the capabilities
that you guys have and the reason why my
children chose you uh is there any
reason is there any thing that you've
done where you can also mitigate that
debt upon coming out the connection
between release
the ending of the term and the
graduating with a degree and getting in
to a position where they can relieve
themselves of that debt would be an
awesome draw to anybody wanting to go
well I think that so our we do a a
destination survey at the end of every
year six months actually after the end
of of every year and the vast majority
of our students our graduates are I
think it's like 90 5% are either
employed or in a like maybe they went to
grad school um telling us that
um their their
degree did what they wanted it to do and
got them a job um I I would add that the
86% receiving financial aid might not
necessarily mean
loans so let me use representative lad's
example if you are a New Hampshire pel
eligible student um there is a granted
guarantee program and we will the
university system will cover your
tuition it's a last dollar scholarship
but if you're a needy New Hampshire
student you won't pay tuition
now room and board is not covered and
that is still expensive so there are
other options right there are there are
options with the pathways from the
community college system to the
University system um we have an online
option so I I understand exactly what
you're saying representative that that
um I was going to offer my I'm now I
have my my old State Treasurer hat
on and um I think a lot of it has to do
with financial literacy of the citizenry
in this country as a whole and
um if people and Granite advant helps
with this Granite Advance helps with
this if people understood what it was
going to mean to take out $100,000 of
debt or whatever it is um well K red
would prob would have to react
differently I suppose but
um it's certainly a a huge issue in the
country I I
totally understand
that okay there going to be a lot of
questions on higher education here
I represent am I'll take that last
question but then I want to switch over
to the community college system because
they have their half hour still coming
up as well go ahead May easy one what
extent do you rely on federal funding
and what prospects for change are you
thinking
about that that's an excellent question
representative um because that that
um the Grant dollars I mentioned that
have increased 75% and drive so much
Innovation and research in the state
it's almost all federally funded
so we don't know what will H you know
what
what we do know right there will be a a
government efficiency Department that
could
impact federal grants we don't know but
we'll have to Pivot if the if the grants
if the grants dry up well then they're
then that would I think that would be
terrible for innovation in the state but
um we'll have to Pivot the other the
other big Federal number and just
forgive me while I look at my financial
statements um the other big Federal
number is the pel grants and so last
fiscal year um we had $22 million in
federal pel grants and I haven't heard
that the pel grants are going to be
pulled back but but that could be
another
impact so it's on our radar um we're
keeping plugged in with various
associations and um to make sure that
you know we understand what What's um as
well as our federal delegation to so we
understand what the impacts are before
they before they arrive on our
doorstep thank you thank you very very
much this is huge and we'll probably
have to invite you back for more
information as as we move anytime
well Chancellor Rubenstein community
college
Reed you know take your half hour
because you
know just like a football game you know
some choose to receive some and some
choose to kick I don't know well thank
you Mr chair and thank you members of
the committee for the record Mark
Rubenstein Chancellor for the community
college system of New Hampshire joined
by my
colleague hi Shannon Reed director of
government Affairs and Communications
welcome if you don't mind before I get
to the actual presentation
representative lad when you began the
earlier part of the discussion with
chancell preventure you had remarked
that in some states higher education is
moved to a different committee and here
we do this together and I I think
there's a logic to it because in so many
ways and it was touched on by chancell
prenter as well education is really
increasingly importantly seamless prek
through lifelong learning
and we often get hung up on the
demographics when we think about the K
through2 population in particular in
fact the task force that you mentioned
that Governor sonunu had charged last
year when Chancellor prevention and I
were providing our respective
presentations we both drew the same
slide from New Hampshire Department of
Education that showed that between 2003
and
2023 the state had seen about a 22% drop
in K through 12 enrollment about 35,000
fewer students and that's not
insignificant for any of us but that's
only part of the story and increasingly
what we recognize is that it's not just
the demographics but it's the education
itself that's changing or needs to
change when I was in high school my
guidance counselor never told me that
you could use a 3D printer to produce a
pancreas there are jobs and industries
and opportunities that just didn't exist
now that that that's 45 years
ago but 10 years ago guidance counselors
weren't necessarily talking about this
and who knows what 10 years from now
will bring that we're still not talking
about and that has implications because
to have the workforce that's available
for industries that are just
emerging we're not going to strand the
majority of the population and tell them
they were born too soon to participate
we've got to be able to make education
accessible to working adults throughout
their lifetimes not just because new
Industries will emerge who knows when
the next regenerative medicine
opportunity but just in terms of how
people's lives
unfold we offer associate degree in
certificate programs and associate
degree in
nursing one in five of our nursing
students already has a bachelor's degree
in some other field but at some point in
life they realize that they're they were
meant to become a nurse and they do and
so part of this the the demographics of
that K through 12 population is always
going to be important for all of us but
increasingly we've got to figure out how
we make ourselves accessible make our
programs accessible to this broad
cross-section of Learners from K
through as long as you want to work uh
to be able to participate
fully a a couple of of additional
thoughts about
that for the community college system if
you'll turn to the packet on slide two
map what you're going to see is that we
are throughout the state and again when
you're
serving working adults in particular
people with family and Community
responsibilities it has to be local now
it doesn't mean that it can't be virtual
too about 30% of our instruction is
occurring online that that's the reality
and that asynchronous on learning at
your pace or I should say on on your
schedule but within a semester a term
that just works better for a lot of
adults but we still recognize The
Importance of Being physically present
embedded in regions connected to
communities to understand what the needs
are and to make those opportunities
accessible for that
population you'll see that in addition
to the map which shows the distribution
of our campuses and our instructional
locations that we also describe three
different ways in which we serve our
students and traditional undergraduate
programs degrees and certificates
primarily on our campuses but not
exclusively again 30% occurring online
but this would be very familiar the
analog to what you would find in a
college or university anywhere
but increasingly our work has found its
way into serving high school students
and again three different ways of doing
that in their high schools something we
used to refer to as running start online
and then also on our campuses depending
on what mode what opportunity works best
for students last year of the 24,000
plus students we served 10,000 of them
were high school students and
collectively they earned 54,000
credits at our tuition rate tuition and
fees $215 of credit for tuition $25 for
the enrollment fee $24 of credit that's
almost $13 million and they did that
virtually without cost to themselves
because the legislature invested $2.5
million to allow us to support early
college that return on investment is
significant and increasingly referring
to the pathways that
Chancellor preventure mentioned if we
can help more students not just take
courses but take sets of courses that
comprise the foundation of Pathways we
can increase the likelihood of students
finding their way to college part of our
reason for wanting to grow this program
continue to grow this program the
original intent of early college was in
fact different than it's played out
nowadays most of the students who
participate in early college programs
are students who know they're going to
college and their parents know they're
going to college and this is just a
financially Savvy way to save on cost if
you've completed a semester a year of
college without having to pay tuition
you're you're ahead of the game don't
take out loans that year in fact you're
a year closer to the labor
market but the original intent of early
college was actually supposed to be for
students who didn't know that college
was a possibility to give them a chance
to test themselves and come to the
realiz ation that they were capable of
doing this and for us early college
postsecondary opportunity isn't just
traditional programs for us it's
automotive and it's welding it's any
number of the trades for which having an
associate degree or certificate is still
a critical part of of a career path for
those students it might might be
somewhat surprising for you to find that
although students who enroll at CTE
centers comprise about 12% of the
state's High School population they're
about 30% of the credit activity in our
early college program these are students
who are recognizing that this aligns
well with their career interest their
personal interest and it also gives them
a foundation for whatever they choose to
do with that education
next so in addition to our traditional
undergraduate programs Early College a
growing part of our work and then the
third part of our our portfolio if you
will work Force programs over the last
several years question earlier about the
effects of federal government uh and
what what changes might bring we have
benefited significantly from investments
from Department of Labor and our
apprenticeship programs Community
College System created apprenticeship
New Hampshire throughout the state we
have four regions again tied to local
communities to help us understand what
the needs and opportunities are at any
given time we're supporting about 300
students in appren
ships and and an apprenticeship you know
we used to think of those in the
conventional trades electricians
plumbers and that's still certainly
important although actually outside of
our scope of practice but we have folks
who have been working with Employers in
the state in Fairly innovative ways
apprenticeships for teaching
apprenticeship for directors for child
care centers most recently we have an
apprenticeship application from of US
Department of Labor for Behavioral
Health technicians to try and respond to
the Frontline needs of the state's
mental health challenges so
apprenticeship as a way of learning
particularly again whether young or
older the ability to earn while you're
learning not to put your earning on the
Shelf while you're while you're
incurring debt or expense for it but
actually to be able to earn while you're
learning just a different way of serving
students that's just one of the flavors
of Workforce programs we also do
business we have business training
centers on each of our campuses
developing programs for licensed nursing
assistance medical assistance any number
of of entrylevel roles and opportunities
or advanced level opportunities to
strengthen Workforce again complimentary
not just to the needs of employers in
the interest of students but
complimentary to the way that their
lives unfold with responsibilities for
for families a and employers and so
forth so our efforts are increasingly
trying to serve this wide spectrum of
students from high school through
lifelong learning while connected to the
workforce trying to deliver programs
that that respond to the the changing
needs that that are created by The
Innovation that Chancellor preventure
described with New Hampshire's employers
and others so let let me pause for a
second and see if anything I've said has
prompted question or need for
clarification uh yeah I have one
question that the $2.5 million you spoke
of that's hitting the student probably
would go to college
anyways if we up the Annie to let's say
three would we T be touching more of the
student you're really aiming at we we we
think that o over the last several Bia
the legislature has increased support
for this from roughly a million to a
million and a half most recently in the
current bium to 2 and a half million
we're asking for three in the next bium
we think that we're continuing to
demonstrate progress and as I said
earlier the fact that said 30% of our
credit activity in early college is
found among students in CTE centers
suggest to me that we're reaching an
audience that in the past in fact we
know over the last few years that that
doubled nothing else right now yes repr
spillsbury uh newcomer question you're
you're color coding your different
locations on this map in a nutshell
what's the distinctions well each of
those colors associate with a specific
College I I should have I should have
addressed this we are
currently seven individually accredited
institutions the the shared colors for
instance with White Mountains primary
location in Berlin uh an academic center
in Littleton uh River Valley Primary
location in Claremont but uh
instructional locations in both Lebanon
and Keen in fact the Keen location is
hosted at Keen State College um I I will
note also that Ro uh Great Bay which has
primary location at peas and a uh
instructional location at Rochester that
location at Rochester is a least
facility and we expect to relinquish
that this year the property has been
purchased uh I I believe it's going to
be repurposed as a a casino uh we're in
the process of relocating our welding
Portsmith
yes thank you Mr chairman it's great to
see you again I I wonder if you could
speak um to us again about the the
corrections and the the emphasis you're
putting on the pathways from nhti moving
towards or from these Tech schools
moving towards the college system and
how you've corrected those things the
other thing is um a question personal
that I never got to ask is there a do
you have that same kind of connection
between crtc and conquered and coming
into the tech thank you we we do the
crtc conquered is one of the largest uh
participants in early college with us so
a handful that that really outperform if
you will uh to your question a as chanc
perent remark we are now up to about a
100 House Bill 1530 from two sessions
ago called for the University system to
work with the community college system
to identify and develop at least 30
Pathways for students to progress from
the community college system the
university system we're now approaching
orh past 100 of those Pathways this has
become much more seamless for students
the ability to know at any one of our
campuses that if you take this set of
courses that this is exactly how they
will map no loss of credit in the
transfer process no need to repeat
courses no delay the opportunity for a
student and a family to recognize that
this is a more affordable pathway as
with our early college the the the best
way to manage debt is to avoid it and to
the extent that we can find these coste
effective strategies and make them
highly visible and accessible to
students throughout the state is one of
the most constructive steps we can take
to help our students and this state have
the workforce that it will need for the
21st
century thank you
sir yes representative fellows um the
the Department of Education has been
using
individual student IDs for almost 20
years now and so there's almost 20 years
of data in a database somewhere that can
tell us um the kids that were in high
school and and how many of those went on
to the university system or went on to
the community college system because you
track those IDs also is my understanding
has there been any utilization of that
data
to tell inform you about you know what
what's
working I I can't speak for what
department of education has done with
the data we have a relationship with the
national student Clearing House it
allows us to know when a student applies
to us but doesn't enroll where did they
end up or when a student has been with
us and leaves did they in fact transfer
to another institution were they
successful there so we we make use of
that data often to understand the
trajectory of our students academic
lives one of the slides you have here is
budget management and where is the state
funding to what degree is the state
funding the community college system
more than half of our operating
budget we are incredibly reliant on the
Investments that the state makes in our
work can you be a little bit more
specific about that you know I I I've
heard from some that we as as much as
90% no no unequivocally not the total
operating budget in the most recent
years is above $120 million House Bill
one in the current banum provides us
with about $63 million additionally in
House Bill 2 between the two years of
the bani a total of about $10 million
but uh student tuition and fees
accounting for about 45 million and then
Grant activity another 8 or 10 million
depending on how rapidly we're we're
drawing down the
grants thank
you yes represent Burton thank
you two
points one one has been mentioned yet
excuse
me record on up migration of college
graduates in country Vermont is first
about over
went oh turn the mic around that helps
excuse me over half of the students who
go to higher red in New Hampshire leave
the
state my point is that the programs you
have that get students employed while
they're in school is is a counteract to
that if if they get a job in New
Hampshire they may well more be more apt
to stay here and and that's one of the
side benefits I think of of what you're
doing the the second thing I just want
to mention was having been a Community
College president was that people will
complain sometimes about admin costs
growing but when you have 100 Pathways
you need advising you need lots of it
and it can't just be done online it has
to be personto person so I I I when we
get into budgets I'm sure I will see the
support that's necessary to support
those those wines and it but it is
necessary because that's what makes them
successful am I correcting that you you
are correct I I I will say one of the
things and I it's taken me some time to
get used to this my early on my career I
was at Penn State at a time when Penn
State was 70,000 students and you're
used to large classes and you're used to
large
numbers our work in some cases just
doesn't lend itself to that and it's for
a number of reasons when you're serving
the North Country to have a dozen
students participating in EMT and
Paramedic program that's a large number
of students when you're preparing a half
a dozen CDL drivers for plow trucks for
the winter season that's a good class
it's not going to be dozens or hundreds
it's also the case that a lot of the
programs that we deliver and you'll know
this from your own experience as a
community college
President one of the areas that
community colleges are essential for
across this country is Healthcare
related programs and the accreditation
standard a nursing program the clinical
ratio of 8 to1 or dental hygiene 5:1
radiologic programs again the close
supervision that's required for high
quality program outcomes just expensive
to deliver and can only be done in small
groups so there's a lot about our work
that doesn't lend itself to the kinds of
of large round numbers that that tend to
get people excited and also that tend to
allow for efficiency it it it's it's
peacework in some ways it's individual
students small groups but it's
impactful I I can as as the interim
president at Eastern main Community
College I can tell you about that Main's
ratio is 8 to1 nursing and that's
expensive I think New Hampshire is 10
to1 8 to1 you're 8 to1 too y that what
that means is you have to have one
full-time faculty for every eight
students and when you do a cost analysis
of any college that's always the most
expensive it's not technology it is it
is Healthcare and it's and that's for a
reason uh because that's how you get the
the clinical supervision to all the rest
of it with those programs but but but
some who know me and who have had to
suffer through my speaking in the past
will will know that when we turn to
nursing for six years in a row New
Hampshire has the highest firsttime
enlex pass rate in the country that says
something about the way the states
colleges and universities are preparing
nurses and it makes a difference in the
health care and the quality of life for
residents throughout the state Eastern
main had
100% okay let's get back to some other
the issues right I'm I'm interested in
hearing you're working with the
university system and in terms of the
transferability of credit and the
pathways to technology used to
facilitate this where are we in terms of
there's been holes there where are we
with the the same data packages between
the two systems well if if you're
talking about the the Computing
environments we're we're in two
different uh networks and moving further
apart right now Ju Just because the
university has made a preemptive
decision to move to a new uh Erp system
and the community college system is not
yet ready to to make that change that
Mark I don't want to just because we're
in short time the Erp program is what
I'm I'm alluding to and we know that the
community college system is going to
have to have the the funding to get to
the level of being able to communicate
on the same wavelength we we've put
together an RFP to do an an assessment
of what it would take for us to
transition to a different platform I'm
not sure that we're ready to do that and
depending on the information we receive
I defer to chance of preventure for the
cost information associated with the
University Systems but more more
importantly that's a four or five year
process so there's no quick solution to
to any of
that thank you do you have
this in in the interest of time I I'll
be efficient to say that that the the
question that was raised earlier that
there's limits to what we can do with
efficiencies but we look for them and
over the course of the last decade we've
reduced our Str our U work by about
30% we've begun to do more with
Workforce programs those short-term
programs we are trying to figure out how
we can better serve students in the
state in what I think is a changing
environment we are currently working on
an analysis of how we're structured as I
mentioned earlier seven separately
accredited institutions we don't want to
give up our connection to the
communities that we serve but we are
looking at whether there are different
strategies for how we structure
ourselves administratively to prioritize
how we serve communities how we serve
the state uh in in more efficient ways
again predicate on the idea that we're
really in a growth industry even if it's
not always apparent we've got to figure
out how to reorganize ourselves to meet
what I think will be an increasingly
larger but different type of demand for
postsecondary education in the future
where are you on the path to single s uh
accreditation we expect with within the
month to have a report outlining a set
of options that our board and other
stakeholders including the legislature
can can review and evaluate I I don't
think this is a decision that we want to
rush but we also recognize that
beginning the conversation allows us to
move move forward in in some meaningful
way and we we hope over the next few
months to have more to
share you'll be reporting to the the
committee on that the highed we we will
be doing that
okay yes thank you Mr chairman and thank
you so much for being here to uh help us
do our work better um you were talking
about reducing personnal costs and all
you know and I was looking at your um
jobs postings and I noticed that you are
seeking a massive amount of ajun
professors I'm assuming those are
part-time instructors that are only
called up as needed and it's basically
the equivalent of a contract position
not a full-time correct just double
checking my assumption I don't want to
assume stuff and get it wrong so we we
have a balance of full-time faculty and
adjunct faculty that gives us
flexibility allows us to engage uh
Talent where we need it but allows us to
also manage the expenses associated with
delivering I've work in that environment
for about 10 years I fully support
everything you said in terms of
flexibility and the ability to you know
just use what's needed and not otherwise
waste res so thank you thank you sir the
the only thing I would add then in the
interest of time although willing to
handle questions slides 11 and 12 uh in
your packet before the photographs
simply a list of Partnerships employers
that we work with throughout the
state this is critical to our ability to
serve students and serve New Hampshire
is to have Partners who help us
understand what their needs are so that
we can help our students with education
that aligns with the opportunities that
list one of our goals is to um help you
all stay informed about the community
college system and what we're doing in
each region and so we have a couple ways
of of doing that you should all be
receiving a newsletter from us um an
email electronic newsletter every two or
three weeks we send it out and it goes
to your legislative emails so I hope
you'll be on the uh on on the lookout
for that it talks about new program
developments and Partnerships that we
have with various employers and Civic
organizations in the state we also have
in the box on the table which I will
leave out our hot off the press's annual
report that I'm happy to share with you
and with it is um this document which is
a a listing of all of our associate
degree and certificate programs across
the state and where they're offered so
that's this is a great resource for high
schools guides counselors really like
this to help work with their students
and help them pursue their particular
interests but we'd like you all to have
that information as
well thank you are there any further
questions from the committee at this
time well I want thank you very much for
coming today thank you for having us
appreciate the work that both systems
are doing to try it
to efficiencies and everything else
you're doing with the getting the
students on the pathways they need to be
on and keeping them in our state thank
you very very
much so with that we are at the
conclusion of our work for today I want
to remind everybody in the committee
that we will be meeting on
Thursday and that will be our first
hp15 thank you very much and and yes
this is good yeah good what was the
other thing which we wanted to mention
here you mentioned something to me
um we talked about ex session talked
about yeah yeah I think we're good I
think we're good too I think we're worn
out yeah
um oh well I mean we're we're talking
about maybe having some of the division
2 Dems come in from time to time when
when you're talking about something yeah
what if one of our Dems creates a seat I
mean I don't know um you know if they
want to ask a question because you've
got three Republicans from division two
that will be you and I talked about this
yeah yeah yeah no but I'm just